ce qui s'est passé moi quand j'étais
enfant c'est que j'ai un frère qui a six
ans de plus que moi donc aujourd'hui
j'ai 27 ans lui en a 34
et quand on était enfant mon père est
décédé quand j'avais 4 ans et suite à ça
je pense que mon frère a été très
perturbé je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé pour lui personnellement mais il a
commencé à avoir des comportements
déviants avec moi des attouchements qui
sont gdg des flashs mois de souvenir je
sais pas exactement jusqu'où ça a été je
sais pas si on peut parler clairement de
viol ou pas mais je sais que j'ai subi
un inceste qui a du coup impacté mon
développement et la femme que je suis
aujourd'hui
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'à
l'époque ma ma mère en fait à vue n'est
fait elle est entrée un jour dans ma
chambre moment pendant lequel mon frère
était sur moi dans une position
clairement sexuelle est plutôt que de
réagir immédiatement
elle a refermé la porte je suis donc
sorti de ma chambre
honteuse puisque j'avais l'impression
moi d'avoir fait une bêtise et que
c'était moi qu'on avait surprise sur le
fait et est en fait suite à ça elle m'a
demandé de me prendre par là ça s'est
passé je pense de mes cinq jusqu'à mai 8
9 ans donc ça y est ça a duré quand même
un long moment et jamais elle m'a
questionné pour savoir ce qui s'était
passé pour savoir jusqu'où ça avait été
enfin jamais elle a vraiment donné ça
sous le tapis et est en fait ma mon
entourage plus ou moins proche à dire ma
tante chez qui j'étais beaucoup à
essayer de me questionner mais ça n'a
jamais été plus loin puisque moi je
voulais pas en parler et je sais pas ce
qui a été
à mon frère suite à ça si on lui a dit
que c'était grave qu'il avait fait que
c'était que c'était interdit qu'il
fallait pas le faire on en a plus jamais
reparlé jusqu'au jour où moi je devais
avoir une vingtaine d'années vraiment gt
gt assez jeune et je l'avais déjà
conscience à l'époque que c'était à
cause de ça que j'allais mal avec
d'autres choses mais que c'était la
raison principale de mon mal être et
donc j'ai
demander une confrontation avec ma mère
ma grand mère et mon frère pour leur
parler de ce qui s'était passé pour leur
dire que j'étais très mal dans ma peau
et que ça m'avait ça m'avait énormément
impacté pour leur demander quel avait
été leur ressenti à l'époque pourquoi
elle n'avait rien fait et en fait la
réaction de ma grand mère a été deux
nient en bloc de me dire qu'elle n'était
pas au courant et ma mère contraire
c'est un peu victimiser c'est à dire
qu'elle s'est mise à pleurer en disant
que qu'elle n'avait pas su quoi faire et
qu'ensuite le temps avait passé et que
et voilà ce que je peux comprendre
aujourd'hui je lui en veux plus je lui
pardonnais de ça parce que je pense
qu'on peut pas vivre avec de la rancoeur
toute sa vie et donc suite à ça avait
logiquement moi j'ai eu des problèmes à
l'adolescence dans mon rapport aux
hommes dans mon rapport aux autres en
général j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à me
construire en tant que femme et et dans
ma vie personnelle et plus
spécifiquement dans ma sexualité bien
évidemment et puis on va forcément vers
des gens qui nous font du mal le maire
des gens qui nous abuse puisqu'on a été
abusée une fois et qu'on nous a jamais
dit que c'était par normal de se faire
abuser donc forcément on va vers des
gens qui qui ont tendance à reproduire
ce schéma là moi j'ai été dans des
schémas d'autodestruction et oued en une
destruction un peu de ce que j'ai été et
c'est ça qui a été le plus compliqué et
en plus de ça c'est très compliqué après
de construire une relation stable farina
je suis dans une relation stable depuis
un an et demi mais c'est la première
fois de ma vie que ça m'arrive que je
m'autorise à être aimé pour ce que je
suis vraiment et pas pas pour le jeu ce
que je crois que je suis est par contre
pensent que mon frère une culpabilité
malheureusement dont il aura beaucoup de
mal à se défaire et du coup ça provoque
aussi de la culpabilité chez moi parce
que je culpabilise qui culpabilise et
donc c'est un cercle vicieux et je vais
parler du fait que j'allais faire cette
vidéo aujourd'hui sur ce sujet là j'ai
voulu être sincère avec lui je voulais
aussi avoir son aile
peut-être un peu son assentiment pour
être aussi bien dans mes baskets et
faire ce que j'estimais de bien il m'a
vraiment encouragée à le faire si les
bourreaux c'est qu'on lui a pas expliqué
qu'ils devaient pas faire ça donc il ya
déjà un manquement de l'entourage à ce
niveau là et en plus de ça oui enfin je
veux dire à l'époque c'était un enfant
tout au plus un adolescent puisque je
n'ai pas de souvenir précis sur l'âge
mais il avait maximum 14 ans quand il a
fait ça donc je suis désolé c'est pas en
adultes idée par le responsable de ses
actes et il
il aurait il pu être jugé être blâmés
pour ce qu'il avait fait mais je pense
qu'ils auraient eu besoin d'un
accompagnement derrière parce que ça
s'est arrêté mais ça aurait pu aussi ne
pas s'arrêter pour au delà des faits qui
sont terribles en soit je trouve que le
pire dans l'inceste c'est tout le
traitement qui après que ce soit pour
l'entourage proche ou lointain et par la
société en général c'est à dire que
c'est des violences dont on n'entend
jamais parler
il ya eu le mouvement nitoo il ya eu
plein de choses plein de de violence qui
ont été abordés dans les médias moi je
me suis jamais reconnu dans aucune
histoire que j'ai pu lire parce qu'on
n'aborde jamais le tabou de lancer ce
même dans mon entourage
au niveau de mes amis par exemple ya des
gens pour qui je sens que c'est encore
très très gênants comme sujet alors que
personnellement je suis ça m'est arrivé
à moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai vécu
moi je suis à l'aise avec le sujet
pourquoi je voudrais me sentir gênés
d'en parler pourquoi je devrais me
sentir gêné de l'avoir vécue alors que
c'est pas de ma faute je pense que j'ai
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire ne
serait-ce que si un jour moi aussi je
veux de faire une version je veux
devenir mère mais je pense que voilà il
ya il ya encore beaucoup de travail
parce que et puis je sais pas si le
travail sera terminé un jour en fait je
sais pas si c'est que quelque chose dont
on se remet totalement j'en doute
je pense qu'on apprend à vivre avec on
peut très bien vivre avec à avoir des
rapports sains avec les gens qui nous
entourent ya aucun souci mais mais il
faut partons de prendre le problème à
bras le corps et il faut pas le fuir
quoi et je veux dire c'est ça qui est
horrible pour les victimes c'est qu'on
vous fait subir quelque chose et après
on vous fait travailler pour réparer
cette chose là donc c'est hyper
frustrant et moi j'ai été pendant très
longtemps dans la colère va me dire mais
non c'est pas à moi de faire un travail
sur moi même
on m'a fait du mal il faut que ce soit
les gens qui répare mais puis tout a
changé le jour j'ai compris qu'en fait
fallait que ça vient aussi de moi et que
moi j'ai envie aussi de guérir de ce à
quoi